now starting all attendees are in listen
only
mode good afternoon everyone this is
Mark Albert editor-in chief of modern
machine shop magazine Welcome to our
webinar sponsored by fanic America thank
you for joining us our topic this
afternoon is CNC programming Made Easy
with manual guide eye conversational
program part five probing without
particular knowledge of gcode
programming it is possible to generate
part programs on the shop floor by
answering simple questions phix manual
guide eye conversational programming
provides this capability for Milling
turning and Mill turn centers with fanic
cnc's part one of this series gave an
overview of the functionality of manual
guide eye Parts two three and four built
on that introduction by reviewing the
entire progression
of creating a basic turning and Milling
program with manual guide ey today as
part five in this series we'll look at
basic setup and operation of the probing
Cycles within manual guide ey both on
the manual side plus Cycles on the autom
mode that can be inserted into your
G-Code programs we'll also discuss work
coordinates tool offsets and measurement
cycles that are standard within manual
guide eye our presenter this afternoon
is Jody Michaels as national sales
manager fanic America jod Michaels focus
is on servicing and supporting and users
to maximize their productivity with the
use of fanic
cnc's jod has more than 35 years
experience in the Machine Tool industry
with various positions in sales support
Automotive applications and training at
Machine Tool Builders and users and CNC
suppliers he is a true expert on CNC
programming and the functionality setup
and use of manual God ey so as we listen
to jod during the presentation please
feel free to share your questions with
us by typing them in the questions pane
on your control panel he will answer
those questions at the end of the
presentation keep in mind this webinar
is being recorded so you will be able to
view the entire program online later
thanks again for taking time to be with
us for the Live program here's
Jody thanks Mark and as you say today
what we're doing is part five of our
presentations on manual guide ey and we
are going to concentrate today on the
probing and again as we did in part one
where we sort of went over the the setup
and everything you had to do to set it
up to do a program today it's sort of
the same thing but it's only on going to
be on probing because because probing
within manual guide eye it's it's very
powerful but it does take a certain
amount of upfront
setup and as I emphasized in part one
it's going to save you a lot of
Heartache if you sort of go through some
of the steps we're going to go over
today because even though it is powerful
it's only as good as how well you set it
up but again what we're going to do
today we're going to show the basic set
set up and operation of the probing
Cycles within manual guide eye and you
have two different types you've got
manual ones where you can just go do one
single thing or there's full-blown
automatic cycles that you can do for a
variety of different things whether it's
measuring tools you know setting your
work off sets or actually measuring
features on the parts themselves with
you know g-codes that you can insert
into a a full-blown manual guide eye
program or a program that you actually
make offline on a cam system you do have
the capability of importing that into
manual guide ey and then adding these
Cycles to that program and we're going
to go step by
step instructions on how to do this to
set your work coordinates your tool
offsets and the measurement cycles that
are standard within manual guide ey now
the first thing that you OB obviously
you want to make sure that you have the
right options you know in your machine
obviously number one you got to have
manual guide eye at some point in the
future some of the probing Cycles are
going to be resident outside manual
guide eye at this point we're not up to
that so you know we're only
concentrating on what's within manual
guide eye and then also you want the
advanced guidance
function and then for some of the the
Tilted plane things that you can do in
five AIS type work you'd wanted the
Tilted working plane indexing function
so these are three options that you're
critical that you need these before you
start using manual guide ey
probing then there's certain
parameters that you need to set and what
these parameters are mainly they go from
parameter 12,381
and all these are setting up pcode macro
variable areas and I know everybody out
there that's listening you know they
understand what that is because what it
does you know when you press a button it
jumps into this macro and then manual
guide eye performs whatever that macro
determines to do but it's important for
all these Cycles to work that these be
set correctly and they go from 1,00
12,381 1 383 384 385 and again these are
all just pcode macro variables all the
way up to
386 and then also
388 and in order to do this to be
successful like number two on my list
here it's important that you have one of
these two manuals that I have listed
here because Within These manuals it
goes step by step by step of how you can
actually set up the the probing
Cycles so between what we talk about
today and looking at those manuals
because you know I mean frankly I work
for fanic but I know sometimes our our
manuals you know sometimes they're
difficult to understand so that's what
I'm trying to address today to you know
sort of fill in some of the blanks that
maybe the manual doesn't talk about you
know so that that's what we're doing
today
also if you're going to use the manual
functions on manual guide ey there
there's going to be some lad logic
changes that's going to be made made to
your machine so some of your Builders
will do that up front some of them do
not so it's critical that you know if
you're wanting to use the the manual
functions of the probing that you go in
and check it and if it's not correct and
it doesn't work chances are that your
Builder has not you know did the ladder
development necessary to make it work so
it's important that you test that out be
before you get all frustrated when it
doesn't work when you try to use it okay
again number two it is you need one of
these manuals and these are two it's the
same number it's just two different
versions the one S7 is the newest
version it these will greatly assist you
when you're set this out and then
another thing I try to emphasize
whenever I talk to customers is that
when you go to set this up it's going to
be something that you're not going to
set up in 15 minutes you know you got
should allow yourself a day to make sure
you get everything set up and you
understand how it works and you know if
you have to do any ladder development
you know don't be under the impression
that when you set this up it's going to
be a 15minute job it will take longer
than that
also the number three another key for
Success successful probing setup is that
you know with most spindle probes you
know when they go into your spindle
whether it's on a tool on a lathe or
whether it's a spindle on a machining
Center in order to turn that on
typically Builders will have an M code
associated with that you have to make
sure that within your manual guide eye
that you build some type of fix form if
you're going to put it in a program when
you call that spindle probe up that you
turn the Probe on because if you put it
into the spindle and try to do a probing
cycle without turning it on bad things
happen and the reason I know that is
because I've done it myself before you
know where I've worked on certain
machines where I thought it was GNA an M
code was going to turn it on to De so
it's critical that you know what that
mcode is and then that you implement it
whenever you want to use the probe so if
you're going to do manual Cycles you
have to go in MDI and turn the Probe on
first okay again I want to emphasize
that make sure that you know what that
is and either make a fix form for the
automatic side or when you're doing the
manual side you go into MDI and turn it
on
first now some of the when you set up
the manual guide eye probing when you
first go into the screens the first
thing you want to do is go into jog or
handle and then you press the settings
hard key and it takes you into a screen
where you actually go up and set
different values C in order to to run
any Cycles within the probing you have
to calibrate all of the different it has
to know the length of the probe and then
the the diameter the stylus on the prob
also you have to go in and tell it the
group number of the tool measure
calibration because you can have up to
six different ones 99% of the time
you're only going to have one but it's
critical that you go in and set this up
up
front and also you go in and again tell
it to Tool measure conditions however
many work set conditions you're going to
have and then this the one down here the
height of plane put reference work it's
critical that put a value in there
because basically what that's telling
manual guide eye is where the face of
the spindle is on the machine in
relation to your your work offsets so
it's important that you have a a value
in there usually it's like your
reference point or if you have a machine
that's like a five axis you know it' be
parameter
19,702 it's important that these be the
same value so that when it does a
calculation for how long the the spindle
probe is it looks at this
first and then these are just a couple
examples of ladder development I just
wanted to throw these in so that you
guys could see some of the things you'd
have to do in order to develop your
ladder on your
machine and again this is just another
one where within manual guide IA does a
measure
cycle now when we actually go into our
uh manual guide eye I'm GNA go to a
different screen now at this
point I'm GNA go back to NC guide now
we're sort of going to go through some
of the screens actually in manual NC
guide and the first thing when we go on
manual we want to go into our jog mode
and you can see this up here on top of
the screen and then as you can see if we
go to edit you know we get different
soft keys if we go into jog it goes to
this and then just to go over again you
know just so we're on the same page if
you guys call me with questions about
this you know all these keys at the
bottom of the screen you know they're
soft keys this right arrow and the left
arrow keys I call those right shift or
left shift so that's just so we're on
the same page so if you call me at
sometime in the afternoon we're on the
same page when I say a soft key or right
shift or left shift but then to actually
get into the the setting page there's
the settings and then it takes you into
that to where we go in and do all the
the calibration and everything that we
discussed and then we go left shift go
back to the measure screen and then
within the manual measure screen as you
can see we got a whole host of different
selections as I say the probing Cycles
are very powerful and just to to discuss
you know the the timing of what we're
doing today mainly I'm going to focus
today on the manual part of it because
there's a lot of things you can do
within the manual side and we're going
to sort of go through all these so we're
GNA get through as much as possible
hopefully at some point we're gonna have
a part two of the probing too but you we
select any of these like probe length
calibration we select that and see it
brings up another screen where
again with manual guide eye whenever you
do a cycle if it's going to give you any
answers there'll be a soft key here so
see at this point it says measure
Direction measure condition and
reference work height so you fill all
those out you know either x minus or Z
minus usually on a prob blength
calibration we're GNA do Z and see it
fills that in then you go down to the
next
one and then for the work K
2.0 and so you just go in and set
everything up then here what it does is
when we do the first one you have a
measure soft key once we get all the
conditions met you press measure and
what it does it goes down and measures
the
tool once backs off and then goes down
and does it again whenever it does a
measurement cycle it always does it
twice Okay so so that's our calibration
cycle and
again this is something you have to do
before you go in and try to run a cycle
you have to go through these calibration
Cycles all right then the next one we
want to talk about the stylus ball
diameter calibration you select that and
again it's just fill in the blanks just
like we've talked about the previous
four webinars that we've done you know
the the great thing about manual guide
eye is that once you've done one cycle
whether it's a turning cycle Milling
cycle boring cycle or whatever or a
probing cycle you know they all look
similar they're all just fill in the
blanks so on this you know the first
thing you'd ask is a reference work
diameter so basically when you set up to
measure the diameter of the stylus on
your spindle probe you will put
something on your table or if you have a
feature on the table a hole in the table
where you know it's a known diameter
obviously you want to have something
that's got a relatively good finish and
it's relatively round because the better
the measurements are on calibrating your
stylus the better things will be when
you actually set a workof set so it's
important you have like a a ring gauge
or a part that you went in and finished
board or whatever but again you put a
work diameter like two inches
then again it's just fill in the blanks
so see it asks you what your work plane
is whether it's XY or YZ again the
measure condition 99% of the time on
this measure Condition it's going to be
number one the only time you'd have more
than that is if you got more than one
type of condition that you're trying to
meet and you're almost never going to
have that then again it asks it asks you
to measure four
different
sides of whatever the ring gauge is or
the feature on your table or whatever
whatever round surface that you're using
to measure that and see then at that
point again it shows a measure
key so again you just go into you press
measure and what it does it goes over
and touches one side you press measure
again it goes over and touches the other
side you go all the way around it and
from that it will figure out the
diameter
of the stylus itself and it'll put that
into a variable of one of the screens
that I showed you before so that it
knows exactly the right the radial
diameter of that so again it's critical
number one that you know exactly the
size of the the origin this reference
work diameter because again as I say
it's critical the the more precise you
are there the better off you're going to
be okay
so that's our uh diameter calibration
and then also you can do
an offset calibration with it you can
have it to where it's offset one way or
the
other okay so you got three different
types of stylus
calibrations you got the standard which
99% of the time you're going to do that
the other two you can have it offset one
way or the other and like I said very
very rarely have I I've never used
either the second two I always use the
first one but again that's it's sort of
depends on how you're doing it but again
99% of the time it's going to be number
three here okay so those are our
different selections on the probe
calibration then also we have a touch
sensor and what this is is say on a
lathe or a machining Center where you'd
have something that was going to measure
the lengths of your tools or the
diameter of your tools so you know it's
like on a a renesa like a ts27r or
Bloom
uh measurement that goes directly on the
table for measuring the lengths of your
tools so that's what this is for and
again it gives you a choice of which the
measure direction is also your condition
and then your reference two length and
ref reference X soft set and
then measure condition and which axes
you want to measure so again you can set
this up not only for a spindle probe but
also a tool probe so again it's very
powerful it'll do a lot of different
things so that sort of gets us through
all the different tab one the C just
calibration Cycles but again you have to
go through these before you go on to the
others because if you try to go on and
do if we go to the next tab where we do
tool measurement if we wouldn't have
went through the this touch sensor
measurement it wouldn't work so we'll go
on our next tab this is tool measurement
and this is usually you know it can
either be for a lathe or Machining
Center but you give it a tool
number you know the direction it's going
to measure whether it's x y z Plus or
minus again your measure conditions
again it only has one so you don't get a
choice and then you tell it whether it's
going to be a a geometry or a wearoff
set and then you just go measure you
press the measure button it approaches
it again it always does it twice it
always does it twice it'll go down and
touch it once back off come back down
and measure it again so that that's the
tool measurement tab now the next one we
have is our work set now I think from
the measurement side on the manual side
this would be the one that that you or
your operators would would use because
you know in my travels and you know I've
done a lot of training over the years
and still do it I won't be doing it as
much now in my new role but you know I
would go into you know different shops
and be training operators and you know
they they might have a spindle probe but
it was always tied to a particular cycle
where you have to run it in automatic
you know they always wanted something
manual what's good about this it is
manual you know you don't have to really
know a lot of different g-codes or
anything like that it's got a pretty
picture associated with it so it's
fairly simple to go through the process
of like the first one single surface
measurement probe z-axis
you know people always want to on a
machining Center they want to touch the
top of that part and do it quickly and
so with this if we select that and again
it gives you a choice of which direction
we want to go you know X Plus x minus
all the different directions so we go Z
minus and again it's
one and of course it comes up and tells
me that I don't have the parameter set
and that's correct because in NC gu I
can't do that and and then I go in and
tell it what my work coordinate is and
when it touches the top of the part what
I want that value to be you know the way
I program I'd always make that zero or
some minimal plus amount but that's what
it wants there then once you do that you
press
measure and what it does it goes and
figures out the difference between your
where you're setting and the Machine
position and then once you go back to
the other side and press set it'll
actually put a value into one of your
work off sets whether that's g54 55
whatever you know one of our 62
different workof sets so it makes it
very simple for your operator you know
within five minutes he can do that you
know once he gets used to it and he's uh
used to going navigating the different
screens in manual guide eye it'll be
within a minute or so he can do this so
it's very important that they go that
through this also we can also do the
same thing for
x-axis and you know it's basically the
same thing you know where you just give
it a direction a condition you know the
work offset that you want to dump the
value to and again if you're touching on
X on one side or the other it'll do the
figuring from
there so it makes it very simple for
your operators to do this and again
that's sort of why emphasizing today
just the manual side of it is because
you know more and more we want we want
operators that number one we want to
make it simple form and then make it as
P precise as possible and with this you
know you can be very precise because
you're using a spindle BR then also you
can do an outside diameter work setup
and with that say you got a round
surface or a square surface you know
where you want to touch on both sides
because you know when I went through
when I learned to be a machinist you
know when we would if we had something
where we wanted to make sure we ended up
in the middle of the part that's what we
would do we'd come and touch one side of
the part then we touch the other side of
the part write down those values and
then subtract them and then divide it by
two and then that's how we ended up in
the middle of the par so you you had to
do all the figuring yourself whether you
had a piece of paper that you were doing
it with this you know the control will
do all of it it'll do all of it and but
again it gives you a choice either XY or
YZ plane the measure condition and then
it sort of walks you through everything
you got to do first measure Point second
measure Point third measure Point fourth
measure point so you can go through and
measure all the way around it and then
it figures out where the middle of the
part is you know it takes
that that calculation out of your hand
which is a very good thing given you
know at this point in manufacturing you
know we're getting to where it's much
harder to find Qualified machinist so
manual guide I will help that greatly
because you know it sort of takes some
of the the questions of how operators do
this you know the control will help them
do that figuring and then once you fill
out all those you tell it what the work
coordinate is and what you want the X
and the Y value to be and then it does
all the figuring for you and then puts
it in whatever work coordinate that you
want it to be it does all the figuring
for
you so it's simple but it's
powerful then if we go back you know
also within that we can do the same
thing if we've got a hole in a
part but again you
know to emphasize again the Simplicity
of manual guide eye you know just like
I've been preaching this the previous
four you know once you SE one of these
Cycles they all look similar so your
operators or your programmers they'll
get to where they're so comfortable with
using this it'll it'll make it very
simple but again you know if we're going
to do an inside measurement again you
got a measure plane a condition and then
the Four Points again it's just we're on
the inside again you tell it the work
offet that you want to
use and then the the X and Y value and
then you press the measure key
and then once it does that it'll put a
value into this window and then once you
do that you press set and then it'll
actually dump a value into your your g54
that's what I typically use so it's very
very good for that also within manual
guide eye we also have where if you have
a feature where it's just a a rib or
whatever the feature might be that
sticking up vertically you can also
measure on the outside of a a rift so
again a measure condition you know the
different directions measure condition
with the two points that you got to
touch you can see the red dock goes from
one side to the other and again just a
matter of setting up your work offset
and what value that you want it to be
whether to the side to the center or the
other
side so it's very powerful and again you
know
over the last four I've also talked
about the flexibility of manual guide
eye because with this again it sort of
gives you a choice of where you want to
go because you know like I said before
typically when I measure something the
way I was trained was you know the top
of the part was
z0 and the middle of the part wherever
that is whether the part was symmetrical
or
whatever the middle of the part was
always X and Y Z that's how I figured it
but there's a lot of uh other people
that use it in different ways so that's
what's good about manual guide eye it
gives you the flexibility of whichever
way you want to go it'll let you do that
so again flexibility is a key then also
within that you also can do an inside
groove or whatever again just take out
your measure condition and
Direction and then it again it's shows
you what you need to do and again that's
critical for your operators that's not
as experience you know it shows them a
picture of what they need to do and then
again you set your work coordinate the
work coordinate value again you press
measure the measure key and then the set
key and it dumps the value into your
work off
set and again just underscore also
within this on the way I've got this
control configured because as as I said
I'm using NC guide which is our offline
software package that simulates a a CNC
control you can also do the C axis
outside and with this again you get
measure conditions and then see it tells
you to go to the plus cais side and the
minus cais
side so it gives you a capability and
you could change this from C to b or a
you know based on different
configurations of different types of
machines it just for the machine I've
got configured it uses c-axis and again
you just give it a work coordinate
value and then a the right work
coordinate
okay then also we do inside width work
setup but again it's basically the same
thing and with that again just fill in
the
blanks and then again you press the
measure key and I know I'm beating this
into your head but I just want to make
sure that you understand that basically
they're all the
same and the last one within it that was
our last one so again that's all your
work set cycles and again like I said
they're all fairly similar and they're
very easy to manage once you understand
what they want but again I just want to
go back again to make sure that you
remember that none of these will work
until you do the calibration you know
it's important you do the calibration
beforehand and I can't emphasize that
enough and I don't mean to keep going
back to it but I just want to save you
heartache up front and plus I don't want
you call me you know saying well this
doesn't work usually you know I can tell
by the the alarms it's where you didn't
calibrated it so the next one we want to
do is a measure function and what you
can use this for is is this will tell
you if you have a feature on your part
or if you have to maintain a certain
length or whatever on a part you can
almost use it like a a CMM it'll tell
you the size of a bore or a size of a a
turn or whatever so it's it's very
powerful in that matter but again if we
select that again it's just fill in the
blanks measure conditions
and then the tool offset kind where you
want to stick it and the target
value okay that's on
Z then we can also do the same on
X again just fill in the blanks it's
very simple just like before you have
your measure key and I know we don't
sell measure right but that's a that's a
translation
thing and then you press the set key
just like you did on all the rest of the
Cycles all these cycles look
similar okay then we get into the
outside diameter work setup and what
this is for is for actually you can go
in and measure the size of
something and you can have it dump it
into there's actually a field within
manual guide iare where it'll maintain a
list you know say you're doing the same
part over and over and over again where
you have to maintain some sort of
Tolerance on a part you can go in and
measure individual Parts you know
whether be every five or every one you
know before it comes out of the machine
it would do a measurement that's what
you could use this for and you could do
it again for several different modes you
know you can go outside diameter inside
diameter outside
width inside width and again you know
all of those so it's very powerful when
it comes to
that okay so those are the four tabs
that we have on the manual side okay
again I'm not going to go back over
these but they're all fairly
simple you have to calibrate again I
can't emphasize enough that you need to
do this calibration up front then you
can do your tool measurement your work
set and your measure Cycles again like I
said the main ones you're probably going
to use is a work setting your operators
will love this because it's simple it's
easy and you can do it in a couple
minutes okay so those are all of our
measure Cycles within our our manual
mode and again to access this you have
to be in the jog mode now to go on from
there to go into our other Cycles you
have to be in edit and then once you go
right shift
you see we have another screen here and
measure Cycles
mcyc that's what that stands for when we
press that soft key that gets us into
basically the same kind of U tab that we
had on the manual side the only
difference between this side and the
other side is that within this when we
do one of the tool measure of sign
the work set or the measure when we
create one of those Cycles we can
actually dump it into a gcode program
and then it'll be just like all the rest
of manual guide ey it will be a four
four-digit
G-Code that it will run in any G-Code
program as long as you know it's fanic
control
obviously uh and again it could be
something created on cam system and you
could put this probe cycle within that
so so it's very flexible from that
standpoint but again we have the same
for and if you the thing about this is
if you say we look at the prob length
calibration you know it's a little
different but when you measured it
manually it's still going to put those
values in the right condition but again
we tell it the the measurement condition
the reference work height where you are
in X and Y and the reason you need more
of this is because this is going to do
this automatic this isn't gonna be
something where you go position it
manually and then press the button and
just do goes and does one thing that's
why it needs a little bit more
information here so that that's why it
asks you a lot more here and then it
asks you for a feed rate and then then
it gives you a range but again I think
you remember this from our from our
other webinars you see these two Fields
have an aster next to them anytime you
have an aster you don't need to answer
that that's just optional
information so that on this one the okay
range and the feedback range you do not
have to answer that information and
again once you do this you press insert
it sticks it directly into your program
and then you could go in and just do the
next thing or you can get out of it and
then takes us into our stylus ball
diameter calibration and I just want to
go through this quickly I'm not going to
go through all of them like I did on the
manual side so they're still very
similar it's just on the cycle side the
inform you have to give it more
information so it asks you for a measure
condition again it asks you for the work
diameter of whatever you're using to
measure to calibrate your stylus the
approach Center Point for X and Y how
far into the parts you want it to go the
approach distance measuring speed
measurement point and then again your
okay range and your feedback range and
again the main reason it's asking for
much more information is because it does
do this
automatically so i' emphasize again that
when you when you use this I would I
would have tried
to to do all this in the manual side
first to make sure everything works to
make sure sure sure that you have the
right measurements so try to do the
manual side first then we cancel out
that I'm not GNA go through any more of
those but if we go into the tool
measurement so see now this one has a
little bit more stuff in it than what it
did on the manual side because on this
see we have Milling tool turning tool
Milling tool turning tool just different
axes to measure so if we go into the
Milling tool measurement you know with
it it's the measurement method so it's
asking for which direction we're coming
from again the condition it's told it's
always going to be number one the
clearance plane a moving
speed and how it
shifts off the
tool whether the Tool's rotating or not
rotating
the comp
number and the reason all these have
asteris next to them is because when you
do
this you would have called a tool up
first so if you don't put anything it
assumes you want to put it into that
value but if you wanted to put it
somewhere else you could tell it to do
that so again that's some of our
measurement cycle that for X but then
like for turning tool and z you know
again it's still just fill in the blanks
measurement method the condition the
clearance modes you know most of these
are all fairly similar and then you
would press
insert and it would put it into the
program but again that's the difference
between the two we've went over so far
the first section was only the manual
mode now we're going over the the CNC
mode and we have two other ones I'm not
going to go over them because they're
basically Bally the same thing as what
we already went over but then we also
got work setting you know again this is
going to be similar to what we went over
before but I I want to go over just a
few screens so you see what they look
like if we select the Za AIS again it's
just fill in the blanks if the control
is going to give you any selections
they're down here as a soft key so we'd
say Z minus measurement
condition zero zero
Z approach
speed and just fill in the
blank and then again we've got all
asteris there we wouldn't have to answer
this information but you can if you want
just depends on how much you want to
find tun it and then once you do that
you press insert and it sticks it into
the
program but again you know you
definitely want to to go through and do
all your calibration Cycles before you
ever get in any any of these and again
with this we do have a wide variety of
different selections because there we
had probe and Z x-axis and z y axis
outside diameter inside diameter outside
width inside width again all the c-axis
ones then you know again like you would
do on a horizontal Machining Center so
you've got all sorts of capabilities
with this you know it'll identify with
almost any type of machine that you want
to make it work on so that's what's
great about all these measurement cycles
and the tool measurement Cycles you know
you can make it work for anything and
again that goes back to the flexibility
of mainu gu ey also we have all the
different measurement cycles and you
know we got 14 different of those also
and with this you know like if we want
to measure in X I'm just going to select
that one again it's just uh
xus measurement condition
one zero and
zero zero and
Z the approach distance you know it's
just your R plan one inch and then a
measurement speed and then again you
know you tell it the comp number what
you want it to end up being and the okay
range so basically what you're saying
there is say say you board something
that was 2 inches in diameter you you'd
say you want to shoot for two inches and
then if it was was not within this range
plus or minus then what what it's going
to give you back you can either just
have it go on or create an alarm or
whatever so it's very it's very powerful
when it comes to
that and then you know also again this
has a lot of different ones you know it
goes we have 14 different measurement
Cycles
also so I'm not going to go through all
these but we'll just go pick one more
out and again just like before to just
fill in the fill in the blanks you know
y minus our measurement
condition zero
zero approach this one inch and then our
moving be 20 inches a minute okay and
again what it does when it goes through
a cycle it finds it backs off it always
measures everything twice although I
think there is a parameter if where if
you didn't want it to do it twice you
could make it not good it but I think
it's better to have two
touches so those are all the different
cycles and again with these cycles that
we've just went over these all can be
inserted into any fanic
CNC that has manual guide eye even if
you do the the program itself offline
you can insert those into a standard
G-Code program that'll read it no
problem uh the calibration Cycles you
know for the the tool Setter you know it
is a little different on this than what
it was on the manual side you have to
tell it's a measurement Direction the
measurement type you have to have a
reference tool length when you're doing
it manually it's a little different the
reference tool
radius you know if you're using a round
tool to to measure the
diameter and then you can either be
setting where it does put something in a
variable or to where it inputs it
directly into one of your offsets and
then the setting setting
destination a reference value or an
offset okay and then you tell it which
axis and then the okay
range so at this point we've sort of
went through all the different cycles
and I know we've sort of went through
them relatively quickly but again you
know what I'm hoping for is that you
know after today you know the main thing
I wanted to go through was some of the
opening things to set up that to
emphasize in order to make this work and
to save you some of the the the
headaches of going through all the
alarms that I've went through in the
past to try to set this up to try to
Short cut that for you where if you try
to do this it'll make it much simpler
for you if you try to set it up yourself
okay so uh at that point let me jump
back into my
PowerPoint
and let me get let me catch up on my
PowerPoint because I sort of went
through the same thing on NC guide as
what my PowerPoint was about and at this
point I'm going to pass it back to mark
because that's all I wanted to cover
today so I'll pass it back to Mark where
you know we can go over any questions
that you might
have okay Jody um I'm here and um that
was really interesting uh it's pretty
clear that this probing functionality is
simple but powerful and I really like
the intuitive nature of it so that that
was a really uh strong message in your
presentation we do have some questions
from our audience so uh let's get
started with those um question here is
the probing
routines are they just calling renesha
9000 programs or fenic specific programs
no they don't they don't use the renesha
stuff it's
it's ver macro variable programs that
that fanic has done it's it's actually
resident in the machine itself no there
the renesa macros are not in there no
okay um how about um can you make Vector
movement
measures vendor v n vector vector yeah
vect not sure what they mean but that's
my question that's the question could
probably measure something on an
angle um yeah it that that's some of the
things that we're working on now to do
stuff you know on an angle yes you can
do that it's capable of doing that
yes okay okay um uh question from
earlier in the presentation um will my
machine do the manual probing right out
of the
box no it will not and that's you know
why you know in the one slide Mark that
you know I want to emphasize that you
know you number one you want to try it
to see if it does good
and then you know if it doesn't work C
basically you know you could fill in all
the values but then when you press that
measure soft key if it doesn't do
anything because that's what you need to
do because you know all the machines are
so different banic doesn't try to set up
the ladder to where it'll work because
it's it's hard to set something up
that'll work on everything so that
there'll be some ladder adjustment to
make the manual probing work for sure
okay um here's another question just
came in um it's getting back to the
vector measurement it says I guess
Vector measurement is used when
measuring a surface with a specified
probing
direction does that clarify something
for us can you adjust
that I think that'd be something that
I'd rather answer you know that's going
to be a a little bit different question
from
what I'd rather you know if I could you
know have him call me afterwards I'd
rather talk about that Dan okay that
that's fine you know just just as a
reminder everyone um you know when they
when you submit a a question you they
should be typed into the question pan on
the control panel it's on the right of
the screen and um you're we're going to
try to get answers to all the questions
but we don't get to all of them while
we're on the air or if some questions
are better answered on offline we'll
take care of that at the end of the
presentation and um you know we're we're
taping the presentation so it'll be
available online afterward um all right
let's get back to another audience
question here
um if using this in place of a renesha
macro program what is the fanic macro
program
number well there's uh you know in the
manuals that you know I mentioned in the
presentation you know there's the all
the the different PE code macro programs
all those programs are all those numbers
are in there because you know you have
to put them in uh a parameter so that
the control will pick up the
right right
macro so off the top of my head I'm not
sure what they all are but there's
there's a lot
okay um another question here if the
specification to the Machine Tool
Builder says this probing functionality
needs to be there can they have it ready
before it is installed at my
facility yes yes that is
possible okay um because really the the
the different changes that you know say
like the the
manual probing that you have to do the
development Mark to do that I mean it's
a fairly simple ladder change but it's
just a matter of getting your Builder to
do it and if you would specify it they
would do it up
front Okay um does a spindle have to be
oriented on a
mill that's that's the question I guess
we're talking about you obviously
probing on a mill yeah okay yeah yeah uh
not necessarily because most spindle
probes today you know that you know when
I first started you know if you use a
spindle probe you had to orient the the
spindle probe so it would face the the
reader you know the spindle probes today
number one they don't have to be like
that you know there's 360 Degrees where
you don't necessarily have to do that
although within manual guide eye if you
would have there is a selection for that
where you could force it to orient the
spindle if you wanted
but it does not have to be youve got
again that goes back to the flexibility
mark it'll sort of do whatever you want
but in most of those Cycles I don't know
if you noticed it but on a lot of them
it had a a tab where it said you know
either Force Orient or disable Orient
for the
spindle okay um here's another question
from the audience U Can the probing
cycle movement profiles be edited or Are
The Movement profiles
preset oh no it's you know it sort of
does what it does so you know within the
cycle itself you know you really can't
get in and mess with
that but you know you can say like you
know I mentioned in there where it goes
down and it does a double touch right
but you know you sort of Define how far
you want it to back off the Speed you
want it to move and all those moves you
get the capability of defining all that
so from that standpoint it's fairly
flexible okay so hopefully that answers
your question I think okay um uh if not
we can you know double check that at the
end of the program this question is a
little more philosophical and it's a
really important one can I can can I use
this for Quality
checking
yes do that yes
yes yes and I've used it for that before
okay you know that's there's kind of a
little bit of a some debate about you
know you know so buying off the part you
know when it's uh just used to probing
on the machine but um you're seeing a
lot of that by users yes yes because you
know especially on Machining centers
where where maybe you're doing a high
volume of parts and you wanted to go in
there and check to see if this bore or
whatever featur is in the right spot
every time and you know for it and you
can give it a
range and you know then it'll come up
and say you know out of range or
whatever so yes it is capable of doing
that it is capable doing that all right
um Joe it looks like we got time for one
one more question and this is just
circling back to maybe the beginning of
the your presentation um how long for
initial setup about how long can I use
figure they're going to need to to get
everything set up for Effective probing
with manual guide eye well if you'd
already have the ladder development
done you could probably do it probably
in about three or four
hours because you because to be honest
I'm I'm I'm probably overly cautious
because you know I'll do one thing and
check it four times before I do it
before I break the stylus off the
spindle Pro you I've done that too many
times so I've gotten cautious so
probably three or four hours if you
already had the development done because
it's just a matter of going through and
setting up all those setting screens
that I showed
Mark once you understand what it wants
and that's what I was W to try to go
over today to to make sure you
understood what it wants there because
sometimes if you look at the the
description of the field sometimes they
don't make any sense
so that's why I wanted to make sure
people had a a for of you know where
they could look at to see what their
they should be or you know where they
could could ask me but no about about a
half a day probably once you have the
latter development
done okay that that that's good to know
um okay Jody uh uh looks like we're
about out of time so I just want to
thank you again for presenting your
slides going through the presentation
and answering our questions it's always
a pleasure to work with you on these
webinars I've I've done a number of them
with you and and it's it's it's
interesting and it's fun so thank you
and um yeah and for all those attending
this afternoon session um you can
contact fic America if you'd like more
information that information's on the
screen right now and if you missed any
of the previous broadcasts in the series
and I highly re highly recommend them
you can find all of them on our website
that's MMS online and just click on the
webinars tab and then uh um you can
choose the ones you want to look at so
uh we really appreciate the time you've
taken with us this afternoon and hope
you found it worthwhile so thank you for
taking part and my thanks also to those
who arranged this session and helped it
go smoothly and um you know with that
this concludes our webinar so have a
great day everybody this is Mark Albert
at modern machine shop magazine
signing off